[موسيقى]
مساء الخير اول شيء معكم نور البلوشيه
اخصائيين
اليوم ان شاء الله راح يتكلم عن الموضوع
في المشاعر بس قبل ما نبدا اول شي اسالكم
سؤال هل سبق وسمعتم عن هذا الجمل او
العبارات او مرت عليكم من قبل مثلا عباره
اه
خليك خليك متفائل دائما لا ابدا لا تتوتر
ابدا دراما كوين
عشرين يوم نتكلم عن فسيفساء المشاعر
المشاعر هذه تكون ونحن صغار جدا تكون
الداخل بس للاسف نحن قضينا برمجه رفض بعض
المشاعر وما نتقبل كل مشاعر يعني مثلا
ممكن حس بالفرح والحب والابتهاج ونرحب
فيهم لكن في مشاعر ثاني نحن نرفض تماما
مثل الغضب الوحده مثلا الحزن التوتر ما
نحب هذه الاشياء
طيب وش الفكره من المشاعر هل هي مخلوق ما
فينا في فكره كل شعور
ومثلها رساله جايه علشان تفهمنا شيء
تعلمنا شيء معين
مثلا بالنسبه ل شعور الحزن
شعور الحزن حزني يخبرنا ان هناك معتقد
سلبي نحن نحملها بداخلنا و هذا المعتقد
علينا شعور البهجه سواء اكان عن نفسي
الاخرين على الحياه في معتقد انا اتبنى
بشكل واعي اواعي عن هذا المشاعر طيب بوش
المغزى والرساله هذا الشعور انه لازم انا
الان اه احتاج اني اعطي
يحتاج ان يمارس
المهارات اللازمه عشان افرغ هذا الشعور
بالضبط يمكن يكون في شعور متراكم داخلي من
خلال هذا الشعور انا افهم رساله الفكره
هذا
الشعور اللي بعدها عن شعور الغرب طيب نحن
كلنا غضبوا لاسباب مختلفه
بشعور الغضب له فكره ولا رساله
شعور رساله الغد هو انتم اساءت فهمي
وتمنى اشعر بالخوف هذا الخوف اللي اشعر
فيه طبيعي
ولكن انا حاولنا وصلت كرتي للناس ولكن
شعوري يطلع بشكل غضب او انفعال ولذلك
المغزى من الوضع الحدود الصحيه
الشعور اللي بعدها عنده شعور الوحده شعور
الوحده يخبرنا الرساله انه هو انا مرفوض
واشعر باني غير محبوب تلاحظ الاشخاص اللي
يجلس واحدهما وينزلوا تكون عندهم هذا
المعتقلات الشعور المغزى من هذا الشعور هي
المزيد من التواصل مع الاخرين وطلب
المساعده
ممكن الاشخاص يكون ينعزل ويمكن ما يحبوا
يتكلموا لكن في فكره وراء هذا الشعور
الشعور اللي بعده شعور يشعر الانسان
النقاب بفعل ما فعشان كده
انا قلت بعدما يخترق قيمه يشعر الانسان
بنت ولكن الفكره ما هي بس اني انا اشعر
بالذنب او يشعر بالندم او الغضب في فكره
اللي هي ان التوقف عنده وتعويض وتعديل ما
يمكن
طيب الشعور اللي بعدها حلو
اوكي نتكلم الحين عن رحله الشعور
طيبه يفهم ان الحين نفى لكل شعور في رساله
من وين تبدا من وين يبدا هذا الشيء فكيف
نعرف نتعامل معها بشكل صحيح نتعامل مع
عشان نعرف من اين يبدا ناخذ مثال على حاله
مثلا انفجر من موقف تافه
او عفوا نبدا بشعور الانتاج
شعوري الانزعاج حسيت مثلا بالانزعاج فيه
عندي عند الطرق مثل ما نلاحظ الرسمي في
اكثر المسار ممكن يقوم الشعور هذا وممكن
اثبتوا
مثلما اشعر بالاستياء او اي شيء ولكن هذا
شيء ممكن يولد نتيجه ان تجر من اي موقف
تاتي طيب في خيارات ثانيه في خيارات ثانيه
هي اني مثلا اقام الشعور ابدى لاحظنا اهم
هذا الشعور اللي حسن وبعدين شعوري اعبر
عنها انا عارف الحين انا اشعر بالانزعاج
مثلا او بالغضب او الشوط الثاني تقبل هذا
الشعور واعبر عنه طيب كيف ممكن اعبر عنها
عبر عنه من خلال الكتابه تامل مثلا عن
طريق الفنون عن طريق الروحانيات او اتكلم
مع شخص موثوق به اتكلم مختص بالصحه
النفسيه اكيد راح يعبر الشعور بالراحه
لذلك هو الخيارات موجود يعني هل استطيع
اني ا قاموا فلما قاموا بضاعتها شعور او
رقم ان اعبر عنها بالطريقه صحيحه
طيب الحين في حال عدم قبول المشاعر اذا ما
قبلت مشاري وش ممكن يصير
ممكن في مشان واحد مزعجه وما مريحه
بالنسبه لنا عن شعور الخوف مثل شعور الغضب
ممكن شعور الندم عبد ال مش احد يريد يشعر
فيها ولكن مهم نتقبل هذه المشاعر مثلا
شعور الضعف نحنا بنحب هذا المشاعر ولكن هي
جزء من انسانيه اذا ما حسين بها المشاعر
يمكن نحنا نكون الناس يكون كان في شيء
ناقصين عدم قبول مشاعرنا
وخلينا عرض الاضطرابات النفسيه ويخلينا
عرضه الامراض الجسميه ايضا كذلك وفي
والدراسات وضحت هذا الشيء ارتباط العوامل
المسير بالامراض الجسديه
والفكره الاساسيه هي كلها رفض المشاعر اي
موقف او اي حدث في الحياه نحنا نحنا
جالسين مع واذا نحن رفضنا اننا نطلع ونفرح
فيه ولا تقبلها راح تصير مشكله واذا نحن
ما عبرنا هل المشكله راح يعطينا شعارات
راح يعطينا امراض يخبرنا انها توقفوا لازم
نعالج هذه الشروط ممكن بعد في حين
ماتقبلنا مشاعرنا راح نتعرض للتضحيه من
المشاعر السلبيه
في المشاعر السلبيه اكثر واكثر نحن نعرف
ان نتعامل معها ولا عارفين من يعني انك
انت ما ما يوصف فيها يعني تمسك فيها
احيانا يكون في الانسان تتعلق الحزن
والغضب والاعلام حتى ممكن نحن نعرض منها
الكبير شيء ثاني ايضا بيخلي الانسان ما
يقبل مشاعر هو راح يبقى منطق طرحته
ممكن يكون فيه موقف ما مريح لكن ان تتدخل
فيه ويجرب الشعور اكيد راح تطلع من منطقه
واحده
وشيك الاساسي عدم قبول المشاعر رفض الواقع
واحداث الحياه لان الاحداث الحقيقه
المشاعر لان الرحله هي تجربه شعور
نشارككم اليوم بهذا اللحم وخصوصا ان احنا
نتكلم عن
انتباهي بشكل كبير لان هي فيها الوان
مختلفه وكان يشبه هذا الالوان بالمشاعر
فيها احمر وفيها اصفر وازرق
فلو شبهنا كل شعور بلون لنفترض مثل انه
شعور الاحمر وشعور الغضب
تخيلنا نحن ناخذ شعور الاحمر هذا الشعور
هذا اللون الاحمر من اللوحه اللوحه
راحت نقط او مثلا اخذ اللون الازرق اللي
هو مثلا نقول انه هو لون الحزن اللي وحتى
ما هي مثاليه ليش لان كل عنصر الهدى وكل
عنصر الفكره ورساله ممكن نحن مع مثلا فكره
ان يكون ضعيفين ونطلب من الباب امام الناس
راح خلينا
وبهذا المواقف ولكن هي فيها اللوحه وهكذا
الانسانيه بشكل مختلف تشمل جدا الوان ممكن
تكون استياء بانزعاج فرح كل المشاعر
طيب في النهايه الحرب اتكلم عن ثقافه
المشاعر ان تبني ثقافه جديده المشاعر هذه
الثقافه تسمح لنا نحن نفهم بالضبط اللي
فينا نفهم جالسين المشار اليها المشاعر
نهرب منها المشاعر اللي ما مريحه بالنسبه
لنا عليها
نفهم انفسنا ونفهم الاخرين و نفهم كيف
التعاطف مع البوسنه و نفهم كيف نواصل
الاخرين وكيف نتعاطف مع اهم ايضا ممكن
ايضا نفهم كيف نتعامل مع شعور معينه شعور
الفقد فقدان شخص عزيز او مثل نتعامل مع
شعور
مثلا الفشل في وظيفه مثلا او الفشل في
علاقه كيف نتعامل مع شعور انه مثلا انتقل
من مرحله الى مرحله اخرى في حياتي مثلا
مرحله الامومه مرحله انها جرت مكان ثاني
مثلا فكل هذه يحتاج لها ذكاء عاطفي ونحن
ما راح ما فهمنا مشاعر نابضه
نحن نحتاج ان نفهم اكثر كيف ممكن انت من
مثلا الابناء الى حدث لاطلاق اول شيء احنا
لازم نفهم الشعور وشعور الامان الابناء
كيف نطمنهم مثلا نحتاج نفهم كيف ممكن نفهم
احتياجات كبار السن كيف ممكن نفهم
احتياجات ذوي الاعاقه مثلا فنحنا نحتاج
المشاعر بشكل كبير في حياتنا علشان انفسنا
اكثر ونحب الاخرين ويحب الحقيقه وشكرا
[تصفيق]